foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for coming
I helped you would
I have a lot to say
we need to find horse week before we
kiss to anybody
you're running out of time
[Music]
you want to die quick
if you want to die screaming
assistant enemies
is it ever
you go after the mountains they'll Crush
you no matter how Bleak things look this
is not the end
none of us are safe as long as she's
still breathing
no I am you know who I am
this world is broken
this isn't the future my mom and dad
fought for
well you want them to be
[Music]
fall back fall back
[Applause]
people remember the last thing that you
do
[Music]
it's very important
how do you want yourself
foreign
stories Walkers that can climb walls and
open doors
I was never sure if they were just
stories
[Music]
I offer for your journalistic pleasures
my life story so
foreign
how long have you been dead
[Music]
the year was 1910 my business was desire
and we introduced you to Mr Lester Leon
core I know who you are sir
we're destined to be very good friends
I'm assuming you only met at night it's
New Orleans days are for sleeping off
the previous evening's damage
that's your thing man you like to watch
how you've been watching you for some
time now I can swap this life of Shame
swab it out for a Dark Gift let the tail
seduce you
just as I was seduced
[Music]
he was my murderer my mentor my lover
and my maker
very strange and chatted boy
as if I could finally receive the
secrets of existence
I could search window
I was not yet ready to hunt but
desperate to feed it's best to let the
food continue
you're not welcome in this home this is
how it has to be
I don't want to kill people you're a
vampire I could not save myself
but I could save her
she'll be what I thought it
we're a family she is poisoning you
against me you two have each other
who am I supposed to love this is
[Music]
we'll be together Ten Thousand Nights a
hundred thousand
ready to begin the adventure of Our
Lives my companions and immortality
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you will be placed in a facility with
other violent juvenile offenders
they could learn from their mistakes by
thinking on their sins
[Music]
welcome to Incarnate Lord
you suffered great pain in your young
life
Jackie's gonna come for us again
bless me father if I have sinned it's
been three days since my last confession
yes right
[Music]
we don't know how many chunkies are out
there
another killer doll with a shady plan
how many of you are there
wait you got a knife yeah I got a knife
they passed them out at orientation
don't make me come back there
he's gonna take over the world but
weren't for that [ __ ] in hell
come in Glenda it's so nice to see your
sweet faces mom who the hell is Nica
Pierce
there is a psychotic murderer I think
she's in love with me and she chopped
off on my lips and she's gonna be
trapped in here for a year mom's a
murderer mom's a lesbian
[Applause]
there is an evil in our Miss and we must
confront it
the MVP of Serial murder
I mean I've killed more people than you
have insta followers
never stop fighting
oh she just died Chucky
I am risen
[Music]
and it didn't even take me three days
[Music]
my life is not the life I'm supposed to
be living
the slushy Shack how may I help you
welcome to Saucy Shack how may I help
you
what
if you always do what you've always done
you'll always get what you've always got
hi Sarah he Reginald you really like her
don't you maybe you should do something
about that girls aren't exactly
attracted to guys like me
dude you look like someone beat your dog
to death with your cat
say sure what do you need
I'm okay
I'm okay
what a weird
dude where the hell have you been
professional you noticed anything
unusual about Reginald Blakey
there's something in that you're not
telling me
what the what what veggie you're a
vampire now you turn these into an
undead creature of the night pretty
messed up right side you kind of sucked
at the whole Being Human thing anyways
oh
I'm prior friends I bet they have really
cool social events welcome to the party
like meet and greets
something evil has this way come I'm
going to find out what it is
we can't just let anyone join our ranks
in order for you to be accepted you will
take part in the vampiric ability and
assessment what happens if I fail the
assessment they die
I adore Bloodshed she will murder
everyone you've ever loved or known
about surprise and then she will get to
work on you being a vampire is not
always worked up to me I don't want to
be a monster anymore
I've met a lot of vampires in my day but
I've met anyone like you
not vampire is defective protest and an
insult to our purity
also I have a surprisingly Dynamic love
life I want you deader than dirt every
relationship has its challenges
I'm looking for Alfred pennyworth
you found him my name is Patrick Wayne
my son seem to think that for the right
price there's nothing you can't do
[Applause]
that's why I'm here
[Music]
what would I do for you Mr Wayne
someone's working on a psychokinetic
drug called a lullaby State
they feed these kids psychedelics so
they don't know their own name
mind control drug once people go nuts
what we're gonna do now we keep going
until we get to the bottom
[Music]
what's Plan B I believe
[Music]
please no more bloodshed
promise
[Music]
we'll need International Help
pleased to make you mad at
[Music]
what the hell the government's
experimenting on human beings you want
something done about this we have to do
it ourselves
[Music]
Hey Thomas never do anything dangerous
whatever game you're playing however
you're thinking of using me think again
this is only at the beginning put out an
emergency bulletin for the arrest of
Alfred penny worth I doubt Alfred can
fix this now
trust me
I've been toying several ideas I'll
explain traveling okay how it works you
should eat your target flip the switch
on the side and Away you go
bloody hell it worked
you have to tell the people that it's
going to be eight years till we're back
to Earth if I tell the passengers that
we are stuck up here and the food is
running out I'm gonna become the next
all-you-can-eat buffet
this is Mission Control is everything
okay
yeah
everything's fine
how can so much light feel so dark I
agree it's my TV show why does she agree
with everything that's said to him you
hate agree exactly
your sister died in space I can't look
up at the sky because it just reminds me
of her so I could only look forward or
down now
it's me welcome back Iris restoring
smart seat to your default settings are
you calling me from the toilet when I do
that I'm a goddamn animal
sorry we're heading into the Sun the big
yellow cancer factory made out of lava
that one
Bernal starved well it's nice to have
options
yeah I think I preferred it when it was
chicken or fish but Twilight of the
[ __ ] Tyrant is upon us
[Music]
happy Pride I say
pray for death tongue combination of
sitting in death sorry I'm just
internalizing a lot of panic and fear
right now
but now I've done that because I'm back
in the room
[Music]
the Winchester story it's always been a
mystery I need to uncover the truth
about my parents
was it the hunt for evil that Drew them
together
but was it something more
to get to the truth the real story means
going way back to 1972. the day Dad came
home from the war love what you're done
with the place we'll sign him up so what
are you gonna do next I have no idea and
the night he met mom
[Music]
oh I'm so sorry
stop helping
what was that that was a demon
what's your name you don't want any part
of this life
you were raised to be a hunter
been chasing your dad since he walked
out our door it was my dad a hunter did
you ever hear a hungry Winchester
I'm Mary it's nice to officially meet
you Mary you're looking for your dad too
right
dad was hunting demons
John lucica John it's okay to be nervous
this is your first hunt at least reach
out to another Hunter who's free Carlos
is nearby our buddy from the alley found
a fresh house
[Music]
come on rookie learn something
foreign
nothing more hydrating than holy water
you want some
I'm good actually thank you Jimmy Janice
Jim Morrison
amen
do all Hunters have such tough
beginnings
the only thing worse than how it starts
for hunters
so you're all in huh I am
when I was a kid I thought there was a
monster under my bed and my dad always
said don't worry son I'm not a trap
my whole life I've been searching for
something
this is good versus evil is the normal
knife for you since yesterday yeah you
know you really are a lot of fun Mary
she's really not mean her when you get
to know her it's a whole other world up
there a dangerous world I was born and
raised a hunter you weren't you can walk
away saving people hunting things Mom
this is what I was born to do
our parents passed there's always been a
mystery and there are questions left
unanswered but I'm on a new Mission and
this story is just beginning as long as
there's a Winchester life There's Hope
it just exploded Nationwide it was a
cultural phenomenon what color is
happier than purple no color
this is Barney and this is what he
sounded like Barney stands for inclusion
acceptance you shall love everyone we
all have Cheryl leech to thank for that
as her beloved character was heading
into the stratosphere people couldn't
accept that this was just a show and so
let the bashing begin
some of the rumors that I heard Barney
hides drugs in his tail they were
violent and explicit to death and
dismemberment of my family I love you
Barney and we're gonna come and find me
and they were going to kill me just the
dark side of this whole moment that must
have devastated Cheryl there was
something larger going on here
I don't think you could ever think
somebody would go and shoot someone
[Music]
it took me a long time
some hard lessons to learn what I know
about chasing Redemption
I was a wanted man with the price on my
head
but for now I was free
I was on the run with no home and no
country
bombaine was a place where everyone
started new
[Music]
you're lucky I was here maybe in my
guardian angel definitely not there's
too much Devon in me for that
[Music]
what brings you to Bombay Lynn nothing
we all have secrets
but not yes sir but only after three
knows it is a two no
my home
this place is not working without
everyone helping each other
why do you help in saravada I know what
I did what I need to pay for
still find a way to balance our bad
they're a man who doesn't want trouble
you keep interesting company
when I ask something of you you will do
it or this place will burn
everyone here is running away from
things
it doesn't work trust me
I'm in serious trouble I'm not going
back empty-handed
you should have gone when you had the
chance
you can be free of anything but yourself
so need to be running towards something
not away from it
hello I'm Helen Mirren for over 52
Seasons documentary now has been the
definitive collection of non-fiction
filmmaking
exactly documentaries exist not merely
to entertain but to invite you to
contemplate Your Existence there is the
world we see where there's also a second
world who lives there what do they have
for breakfast some of you may know this
decks well all of you know this next
song
[Music]
it's just my heart the painstakingly
curated Series has transported audiences
yeah I cry
quite hard celebrating the world's most
exceptional filmmakers and the
extraordinary stories they have told
when you lean into a rhyme you shatter
the conversational tone of the lyric
it's like nails on a Blackboard to me
and I love you all
right this was radicals
and now I'm pleased to announce the
return of documentary now for its 53rd
season
action
Lulu gave you a gift why I was closer to
Lulu than I had ever been to another
human being that must shoot Bachelor
Nanny here the Ula mountains before we
begin I'm gonna read a list of crew
members who have died of exposure
no one can see this
two men end of a sheep pen take these
grugs and pull them at one another
with great force Alice love
it does look like they're just moving
the hair about
oh dear
I wandered into what I thought was a
porno feeder it turned out to be an art
house Cinema stories that dare to tell
the truth I've never been more crucial
to our culture
now more than ever the world needs
documentary now
[Music]
Glenn Fisher
your skills and personality
are being sadly wasted in this den of
imbecility not good or not this year is
the only world that I got
[Music]
what is that
the future just give me that I promise
not to tell anyone
but you almost look happy
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
you're inside what we call a peripheral
what do you mean
you think this is a game
[Music]
but it's real
it just hasn't happened yet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Williams got looking fine on Instagram
hey Connie what can you please help me
rub cocoa butter on my engorg's
pregnancy belly so you're really
pregnant and you're really having a kid
we're having a kid oh man I guess [ __ ]
that happens on human resources affects
big mouth too I guess so and that
affects my life no it affects our life
Connie our life
it
so few brands have meaning anymore
[Music]
but whenever I stay at any of the White
Lotus properties it's always a memorable
experience always
enjoy exclusive rewards inside our petal
and Blossom circles
immerse yourself in luxury at the White
Lotus
we're waiting for you